qui a dit que le rugby était réservée
aux gars du sud ouest en banlieue de
paris aussi ont fait chanter le cuir et
bien au delà nous sommes sur le terrain
d'entraînement de cergy pontoise et lui
ce n'est pas l'entraîneur de l'équipe gm
a été bannie vient de clichy il garde un
oeil sur tous les algériens qui joue au
rugby en france sa fonction coach de la
sélection nationale d'algérie le premier
du nom on nous voir un joueur de la
sélection c'est le petit bonhomme là le
numéro 11 fouad à jimmy qui joue à l'ale
avec la sélection et qui joue ici en à
cergy dans le coup d'oeil pour
le rugby algérien il est en fait née sur
les gazons paris avec des garçons comme
fouad de mère française et de père
algérien le jeu à 15 il y est venu un
peu par hasard elle n'aurait jamais
pensé représenter un jour ses aïeux du
maghreb mon père est né pas eu que du
tout beau qu'il a je pense pas vraiment
réalisé
combien ça pouvait être important pour
moi mais en tout cas il était fier
et fier de pouvoir porter ce maillot
premier maillot d'ailleurs que je lui
garde étiqueté sport de colons en
algérie le rugby n'avait pas franchement
la cote il aura fallu attendre un demi
siècle et le retour balle en main des
enfants d'algériens né en france pour
que ce sport soit acceptée au pays
l'aventuré commence en 2007 du côté de
paris à l'époque la coupe du monde se
préparer dans les clubs de banlieue de
gmail fait les comptes les franco
algériens ne manquent pas ils sont loin
d'être manchot gmail s'improvise alors
sélectionneur première victoire en
tunisie sans structure ni subvention les
joueurs ont tous mis la main au pot pour
porter le maillot
mais la sélection
chaque fois un maillot différent parce
que jusqu'à présent on n'a pas de vraie
sponsors officiels parce qu'on a passé
des rations donc chaque fois qu'on a
quelqu'un qui veut donner un coup de
main à cette belle histoire et barras et
nous on offre les maillots gentiment et
on joue avec
le chantier aujourd'hui créer la
fédération algérienne de ballon ovale
c'est dans son appart à clichy qu'ils
pilotent le projet ici trônent les
souvenir tout frais des pionniers du
rugby en algérie sélection nationale est
là c'est mon petit frère salim et à
sofia aussi deux piliers qui est qui
préside en bon rang
qui président du club d'oran qui lui a
donné un gros coup de main et bien j'ai
rien donc
voilà c'est pas redouter à une partie de
l'achat qu'un s'investit dans son coin
d'algérie pour développer le rugby vient
pas que la sélection la sélection c'est
vrai qu'on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure mais le plus important pour moi
c'est vraiment les gosses qui sont
d'accord
c'est énorme c'est du bonheur pour cet
ancien joueur pour le plaisir c'est
surtout la formation des marmots
acheminer du matériel décrocher des
subventions obtenir des agréments djemaï
fait la navette dix fois par an pour que
les bambins là bas après nantes a porté
le ballon en trois ans il a créé une
dizaine d'écoles aux quatre coins du
pays déjà des centaines de gosses se
sont jetés dans la mêlée
surtout les quasiment tous les stades
algériens on est parti on a fait de la
formation d'éducateurs et voilà des fans
de balle ovale quoi là on peut voir les
filles en train de jouer ça aussi on
instaurer dès le début pour dire que
voilà le rugby c'est la mixité c'est il
n'y a pas de frontières par rapport à
quoi que ce soit
c'est aussi bien pour les filles que
pour les garçons et là c'est sur mon
terrain et moi je suis là en étant petit
son terrain de clichy il en connaît la
moindre mode de terre ils n'étaient pas
plus haut que trois pommes quand il est
tombé ici dans le chaudron du rugby
et bétamèche venu ici pour m'inscrire au
foot là enfin le groupe n'avait pas de
foot
je me suis avancé vers le stade là bas y
avait du bruit et c'est là bas où j'ai
commencé à faire de ma passion gmail est
arrivé en france dans les bagages de ses
parents à l'âge de trois ans grâce à eux
depuis gamin il pratique la mêlée des
cultures retour au bled tous les étés il
passe du français à l'arabe aussi vite
qu'une balle haleine
pour voir grandir djemaï et ses quatre
frères et soeurs madame tebani faisait
des ménages pendant que monsieur
travailler sur les chantiers aujourd'hui
même si le fiston ne roule pas sur l'or
pour sa maman la réussite est ailleurs
c'est vrai à la france au nez on est ici
c'est vrai des panneaux on y allait bien
on est là donné beaucoup de choses la
france c'est vrai mais je voudrais aussi
pour la gérer comme ça je suis très
content pour mon pays ici et pour les
enfants de là bas et
la connais pas le rugby ça fait ça fait
ça fait plaisir
le blade clichy la famille elle rugby
djemaï sait d'où il vient il a trouvé en
algérie un terrain vierge à défricher
désormais lui tarde d'avancé un moment
ces données en oxygène eau j'ai besoin
de me ressourcer au moins au moins une
fois par mois une fois par mois moi dès
que des passerelles et un mois et demi
ici je peux sans impression que sans la
paix quoi donc
besoin d'y aller mais quand il n'est pas
en algérie djemaï reprend son souffle
avec les bambins de clichy il est
éducateur au service des sports de la
ville et entraîneur au club de rugby
raffut touche regroupement le mercredi
le samedi il apprend les fondamentaux
aux poussins du club
[Musique]
c'est pas fini longtemps le ballon lama
petit côté petit côté petit
l essai
têtes blondes brunes ou rousses entre m
sila son fief en algérie et clichy
djemaï travail à l'union méditerranéenne
du rugby ça vous plairait l'année en
algérie nous on a que comme ça vous leur
apporterez des ballons parce qu'il ya
pas de ballons là bas et puis vous
verrez comment il voulait des enfants à
bord
bas frais des supers copains moi je mets
ma petite équipe là bas moi petite
équipe ici donc les voir des deux
équipes s'affronter ce serait vraiment
pas mal ça me ferait vraiment plaisir
allez
aujourd'hui djemaï rêve d'une affiche m
sila clichy en attendant france algérie